it's not often all political groups
unite around an issue but when the
Commission proposed a new law on
genetically modified organisms allowing
member states to restrict ban or allow
EU approved GMO food or feed em eps did
just that anything closing element often
though the page new neon is then fry up
in a marked when we are here with a nut
Sonali tool awesome to Larson building
done burning or open grande nominee the
grants control or indeed democracy is
about listening to the people and the
people of Europe have consistently
expressed the opinion that they don't
want GM foods currently GMOs can only be
used after they've been authorized by
the European Food Safety Agency one crop
maze is cultivated more than 50 other
GMOs are imported in protein enhanced
animal feed many opponents argue GMO
safety for humans is still unproven and
cite the danger of cross-contamination
field to field how we can control the
movement of track from one counter two
hours only to control the GM GM l
movement it is crazy Commission is
turning up with a proposal that give the
Member States the opportunity to opt out
on the import and the use of imported
GMO food and feed this is not correct
many also demand it's stricter labeling
of food containing GMOs next stage is
unclear mep s demand a new proposal the
Commission is refusing a political log
jam which means this status quo stays in
force
Oh